[Müzik]
çok güzel ve çok anlamlı bir eğitim
aldığını
düşünüyorum 4 sene boyunca inanılmaz
derecede kendini yetiştirdiğini bir
içtiğimi çok
iyi 4 sene orada çok yoğun ve
sert bir şekilde Baya da zorlanarak çok
yüksek seviyede eğitim almıştım üçüncü
sınıfa kadar çok iyi şekilde okul
hayatına giderken 3 sınıftan sonra
aldığım eğitimini içinde bazı
eksiklikler olduğunu acaba Bunun manası
anlamında da tamamlanması
bir dörtlük
teyiz ve gördüğünüz sınıf
[Müzik]
ta işte buydu Aslında diyorum
baktığı eserleri ne yapmam gerektiğini
bana hiçbir şey öğretmiyor bana ama bu
felsefede değil benim için inanılmaz
derecede
ısıtma açmam gerekiyor
ders oluyordu
1996 yılında Türkiye çapında ödül aldı
1998 yılında aldım 1999 yılında Dünya
çapında ödüller aldım arkadaşlar çok iyi
bir eğitim alıyordum çok başarılı bir
öğrenciydim
[Müzik]
cümle Matrix filmi
vizyona girdiğinde
arkadaşların herkes bize neonun nasıl
kurşunlardan kaçtığını ve nasıl kavga
ettiğini bahsettiklerinde Ben bir
gün sonuç içerisindeyim Allah Allah ya
ben aynı film izlememişim
[Müzik]
Çünkü filmde asıl anlatılmak istenen
aslında beni vurduran çok önemli bir şey
vardı filmin senaryosu gibi arkadaşlar
yani bir hikaye bu kadar güzel
anlatılamazdı benim için Ordu'da kendini
Bilmem gerektiğini ne olduğunu tahminle
karşılaşması
vesair inanılmaz Muazzam insanlık için
çığır açacak çok güzel bir
olması beni çok
etkiliyor bütün sıra arkadaşlarım dönemi
arkadaşlarımın hepsiyle aynı işi
yapıyorduk ama farklılaşmamız
gerekiyordu
onlardan bir farkının olması gerekiyor
Tıpkı şimdi sizin yan yana olduğunuz
arkadaşlar gibi arkadaşlar sizi ayıran
tek şey
Dolayısıyla
[Müzik]
ben ve
hayatımın Üstadı olmak istiyorum
ve 99
ve yaklaşık 6 ay sonunda öğretim
görevlisi olarak Benim oraya davet
ettiler ve orada Öğretim görevlilerine
başladı 23 sen
ede orada devam ediyor
[Müzik]
1999 yılından mezun olduktan sonra çok
hızlı bir şekilde iş hayatına giriyorum
ama iş hayatında inanılmaz şeylerle
karşılaşıyorum Çünkü şöyle bir durum var
biz dört sene boyunca sanat eğitimi
alıyoruz Ve mezun olduğumuzda Ee
topluluğu ülkemi aydınlat
abilecek vizyonda mezun olduğumuz
zannediyorum oys
Aki dışarı Ben Büyük bir şaşkınlık
içindeydim Cem Yılmaz
'ın duvara toslamıştım
ve yemeğe nasıl olurdu benim okulda
öğrendiğim Sanat ve tasarım ile ilgili
olan hiçbir şeyin dışarıya hiçbir
bağlantısı yoktu arkadaşlar
Ben de büyük
[Müzik]
bir diyordu kendimi bir akvaryumun
içinde dışarıyı gören ama hareket
edemeyen bir balık gibi
hissediyorum Beni inanılmaz derecede
zorluyordu Kalbim sıkışıyor kendimi
daralmış ve huzur
suz Bu arada tabi bunları yaparken işte
Yani herhalde aldığımız eğitimle alakalı
birkaç tane firmalara çok özel bir
şeyler
yapıyor Bir tane bir saat markası var ve
o saat markası
Türkiye'ye getirdiği bir tahminim dünya
çapında bir marka var ama ürünler
satmıyordu ve ben bunları şimdi tasarım
yapıyorum ve tasarım dünyada satışta
birini istemeye gideceksiniz o arada
genel müdür beni Ee toplantıya çağırdı
Hocam dedi Nasıl olur dedi
neden Şaşır
şaşırmıştı kendisi dedi bana Ben de ona
ona ben ruhumu kattım Başka ne bekliyor
dunuz bile Çünkü
öz ve ruh her şeydi aslında Yani aslında
sırf dışarıda gördüğün
mü yoksa arka tarafta görmem gereken bir
bizden gizlenen ya da bizim
algılayamadığımız başka bir hikaye mi
vardı yani ve bu dünyaya varlık amacım
ve geniş amacım neydi acaba Dolayısıyla
hep
imiz
[Müzik]
Çünkü yanında ki arkadaşından ya da
sınıfındaki arkadaşlarından bir
farklılığımın olması gerekiyordu Ve bunu
bilincine varıyordum arkadaşlar
iş hayatında çok ciddi deneyimler çok
ciddi deneyimlere sahip olurken
bir sürü Tabii ki başarısızlıklar ve Çok
canını sıkıldığı dönemler oluyordu
kendimi yardırıyor Çünkü benim
yazdım inanılmaz derec
ede negatife
[Müzik]
yaşım ilerlemiş
yaptım aslında
Çünkü düşük frekanstaki İnsanlar
kendilerine normal frekanstaki insanlar
başkalarına ama yüksek frekansla hiç
kimsenin ama hiç kimsenin kendini
yargılamadığını öğrenecektim arkadaşlar
ve bu benim için inanılmaz büyük bir
dönüm noktası ile nasıl
temmuzsuz ve negatif ne kendini
kodlayabilirdim Oysa ki ben
bu dünyaya geliş amacını herkesten
farklı olduğunu çözmeye çalışan ve
yorumlamaya çalışan bir insandım çok
güzel bir okulda okumuştum bir sürü
Başaran vardı ve kendimi sürekli
geliştiriyorum hayattaki şeyden birisini
seç
mek ve geliştir
mek bize gelişmek için acı çeken
ve bundan sonra da ona devam edeceğiz
Ben hep okul hayatından sonra yaptığım
şeylerle farklı bir şeylerin yapmasını
yapmayı idealdir diye düşünen bir
insandı herkesin yaptığından farklı
olmalıydım Çünkü bu dünyada 150 trilyon
ücretten oluşan 50 trilyon akıllı hücre
ile bu dünyaya gelmiş hepimiz şu andaki
herkes gibi bütün dünyadaki insanlar
gibi böyle bir varlıktı ve evlilik
programı müjdeyle geçmişteki
atalarımızdan aldığımız bütün deneyimler
yetenekler ve Bence evrenin ve yaşamın
sırrını da içimimizde saklıyorduk Ama
buna sanki ulaşamıyorum ve bu bir iç
imizde Hep aramak var diye düşünmüştüm
Ya hep onu arıyordum aslında
[Müzik]
daha herkesin baktığı bir şeye farklı
bir şekilde bakmak demektir ve ben
herkesin battığı ve yaptığı gibi sanatın
icra etmek yerine Gerçekten kalbimi ve
nefesini dinleyerek bu dünyaya geliş
amacıyla çözerek herkesten farklı bir
şeyler yapmak için çok çaba sarf ediyor
öğrencilerin bana hocam yaptığım
Çalışmalar nasıl olmuş dediklerinde
kendilerine arkadaşlar
Rönesans döneminden bir tane sanatçı şu
anda burada olmuş olsaydı yaptığınız
hissede ne derdin diye sorardım
kendilerine Bence siz hala burada
mısınız derlerdi Ve ben hala burada
değil izlemek için bu dünyaya gelmenin
farkına varıyor
dum birazdan göstereceğim şeyler dedi
uzun birkaç tane adını göstereceğim
kendimi gözüme kendime güvendikçe ve
inandıkça
neler yapabileceğine inanamıyorum her
gün gelişiyor Her Gün üstüne bir şeyler
koyuyor ve genişçe kendime olan
hayranlığım artıyordu burada sizlerin
bakması gerektiğini söylemek istiyorum
açıkçası
Evet
bu arabayı içinde herkesin yaptığından
farklı şeyler yapmak Hikayemiz diye
küçük resimler yapmaya mikro resimler
yapmaya başlamıştım ve herkesten
yapılandan başka bir şey yapmak
istiyorum az çoktu ama küçük de büyüktü
aslında az çok Evet Dolayısıyla ben çok
büyük bir tablo değil de çok küçük bir
tablo yapabilirim Ve bunu
çok inanılmaz derecede kullanabilirlerdi
bu süreçte
tabii ki ama iş hayatında başarılı olma
yolculuğundan büyük deneyimlere de sahip
oluyor vladığınız Putin
bana Obama
Donald Trump ve Burada gördüğünüz bütün
eserlerin hepsi bana ait
ve tabii Portekiz Prensi Türkiye de
birçok siyasi büyük iş insanları çok
ünlü sanatçılar çok yönlü bir Sporcular
benim hayatıma dahil oldular Çünkü onlar
beni çekiyorlar ben
onlar onlara Ben başka bir hikaye anlat
ıyor benimle aynı dilimde
yolculuğa
ve bildirimleri de oluyor
peki peki Ben neden mikro sanat
yapıyordum
yamalarda olabileceğini çok önemli bir
sözü vardır hiçbir tablo bitmemiştir
diye bu benim için de çok önemli bir
şeydi Çünkü okulda
ödevler
[Müzik]
Ya ben hala o ödevleri
Yani hala çalışıyor bıraksalardı çünkü
daha çalışacaktım ya Nasıl olabilir
bu büyük bile aynı
gündeyiz ben değilim tabii ki ama en
azından onun izinden gittiğimi
düşünüyorum ve benim
[Müzik]
eserdiğim için sebebimde ikinci sebebin
Zeki çok inanılmaz derecede algılarını
açık ve farklı bir dünyaya doğduklarının
farkındaydı Ben de onlara ulaşarak
onların görsel hafızalarında ilgi
yaratarak kendimi gelecek nesillere
taşıyabilirim inancındaydım açıkçası
çünkü
risale-i salonuna gittiğimde sergilerce
Genelde çocuklar olmaz bende 6 yaşında
bir çocuk neden servis zamanında
dolaşmak dolaşmaz diye düşünüyorum
dolaşmaz Çünkü çok
[Müzik]
ama ben
Hani bir sergiye katıldım
orada sadece yarım santimlik bir tablo
yapmıştım çocuklar tabi çok ilgilenip
çekilmişti Çünkü Mikro bir şey de öyle
yürüteç vardı beni hiçbir zaman öyle bir
şey görmemişlerdi yani 3 milimin içinde
bir tane Bülbül resmini görmek çocuklar
için inanılmaz bir deneyim gibi
algılayan alnında seçicilikten dolayı da
beni ayır dedi sanatımı daha ileriye
taşıyabiliyor
diğer bir sebep ise
mikro resim yapmanın diğer bir sebebi
ise
giyilebilir sanat birliği ile
bütün sanatseverler
eserlerini ya evlerinde ya iş yerlerini
ya da lüks galerilerde görüyorlardı ama
ben neden çok güzel bir tabloyu kendi
vücudunda taşıyamayayım ki
telefon donduktan sonra
bir genç arkadaşlarımız Bizim de işte
çok büyük hayallerimiz
var İtalya'ya gidelim Orada işte çok
güzel sanat yapalım falan ama
bugün de orada yaşamak anlamında birçok
defa gidip seyahatler oldu ama
Ak gibi bana
[Müzik]
Ben İtalya'da doğdum işin biraz daha
kolay olabilir
di güzel bir Kadim bir ülkede doğmuş
olmasının benim üzerimde Vermiş
olduğunuz sorumlulukla beraber
Kendimi daha fazla aileyiz diye
kapılıyorum ve burada yapabileceklerimin
hem aileme hem çevreme
Dolayısıyla
[Müzik]
Tabii ki burada yurt dışında yaşamış
yani ve tamamen bulunduğu dışlamak için
söylemiyorum ama ben sanatla ilgili bir
insan olarak burada doğmanın sebebinin
bu farkına varıyorum Aslında neden
burada doğdum O zaman
Şu an belki aydınlatabilirim
diyebileceğin farkına varıyorum
bir ışıksam sizi aydınlatan insanlar
[Alkış]